Athena is ready to keep pushing forward with her understanding of acoustics to
help out with Concert Hall design. As before, she's still pretty concerned with
how well audience members will be able to hear the music from different places
in the concert hall. Now, however, she's worried about Reverberation time. This
is basically how long a sound echoes for after it's been produced. Athena has
figured out a simplified equation for reverberation time in the hall. The
equation is, T equals 0.322 V over A. Here, T stands for Reverberation time, V
is the volume of the hall, and A is the surface area of the hall. So, to figure
out the reverberation time then, Athena is going to need to find the volume and
the surface area of the room. On this diagram of the hall, I've written in the
dimensions of each of the sides. It's not super important right now what x
stands for but just so you know, it's the depth of the stage back here. This is
how long x is. Considering each of these lengths, what is the volume of our
concert hall?